when it comes to esports few things
matter as much to competitors
as legacy they're the hallowed lasting
memories of individuals that remain long
after their days in the spotlight
inevitably come to an end now it's time
to open a new book right now my story
ends here but i still
even with me gone i still want everyone
to support
tsm and all of
all of my teammates
now in a perfect world most players
prefer to be remembered exclusively for
their awe-inspiring triumphs the moments
where they cemented their place into the
history of their respective games i just
say
all of maester i love you
and second
god help me and i won't measure
but the thing about legacy
is that you don't always get to choose
what it is you're remembered for you can
be immortalized for making an
unfortunate mistake or for losing
yourself in a specific moment he did it
justin wong once again at the top of the
mountain and in the case of martin
jankos jankowski there's a lot to choose
from like his goofy personality
[Laughter]
his reputation for being bloodthirsty
royalty [__] gonna be tank at the
turret aggro here for now the shot is
gonna be
shot the ankles might be able to make it
too
ladies and gentlemen for the first blood
king brings three bloods into the top
lane just five minutes in and his
insatiable appetite for victory
over the course of his eight-year
professional career yankos has enjoyed
tremendous successes but more recently
he's become associated with a certain
kind of hilarious failure his complete
and utter inability to land a nidalee
spear
what very funny
very [__] hilarious
oh okay this field did not miss by the
way the crab is bagged
what so how is it that europe's greatest
ever jungler can't hit a skill shot to
save his life is it confirmation to his
critics that his best days are actually
behind him and with his stream becoming
as popular as it is does yankos even
really need to prove them wrong being in
esports is really
stressful like really stressful
like playing permanently and trying to
win and
getting hated by fans because you lost
and
like this is really really stressful i
think
and um i lost all my head because of it
all right so before we dig into yanko's
story i am going to ask that you like
the video subscribe to the channel and
turn on notifications and if you're
feeling extra generous check out our
latest series unmuted where you can
watch me interview and play games with
some of your favorite esports
personalities okay so if there's one
thing you should know about yankos it's
that he is without question one of the
greatest league of legends players
europe has ever produced they get in
there odne getting suppressed he's gone
down but mouse his ga is gonna get
popped vander a little bit too low in
this one it is just he's stolen from
what the steal away yanko secures hey
absolutely massive elder drake and adg
are evaporating on the spot it's good
bye binko goodbye everybody and how you
gonna think that is good by game but
even if you somehow haven't heard of the
guy chances are you've definitely
heard him
no no no no no no no
could hear yankos from the caster desk
with my
soundproof earphones on or whatever they
are as well
delivering
but despite being a loud naturally
animated fellow there are some things
that yankos prefers to keep quiet about
that's yeah
i'm located
that like keeps it secret because
i saw a mic check last year where you
said
that someone oh [__] no don't bring him
back
and contrary to what you might have
heard he is something of a ladies man
why am i like why did you send someone
when i'm talking about being horny why
did you send it why does it always
happen to me
why can you just not
can you just
ah anyway on the rift yankos and the g2
super team terrorized the scene for the
better part of two years and made the
rest of the world finally give eu the
international respect the region
deserved this is what peak league of
legends looks like and it comes from
europe a world record g2 esports 3-0
will win msi 2019
but in 2021
things began to change perks g2's
long-standing mid-turned adc decided to
try his luck in n a and so the org
brought in reckless to replace him he's
like hey guys sign me because i'm
reckless and and i'm good at the game
and i'm handsome and and and i'm cool
and and i have big fan base after such a
significant roster change the new look
g2 did all right in 2021 taking third
and fourth place in the lec spring and
summer splits respectively but all right
was a far cry from the success the
previous iteration of the team had
enjoyed so what do you do when things
aren't going as well as they used to
well as is the hallowed tradition in any
esport when the team isn't quite getting
the results you want
you blow the roster right the [__] up
and start over when the dust had finally
settled the only two remaining pieces of
europe's greatest ever league of legends
team were caps and yankos they became
the foundation for the roster's newest
iteration and that was a decision not
everybody agreed with so i go to carlos
and i'm like hey carlos i'm washed up
i went one nine with graves in solo
queue i cannot be good anymore um you
should get self-made
and then carlos is like you know what
you are right you are so bad i wanted to
kick you a long time ago but you had
like nice fan base i stick with you and
as is typical in this lovely totally
non-ageist industry of ours the biggest
criticism being levied against yankos
was the fact that at the tender age of
26 he was getting
old you see it is a well-documented fact
that playing league professionally
accelerates one's aging by a staggering
well according to the game's fan base
anyway thus your average 26 year old
league competitor actually boasts the
mental and physical faculties of a 52
year old if players fail to maintain the
same competitive form over long periods
of time it obviously has nothing to do
with burnout exhaustion or meta changes
it's purely a result of senility early
symptoms include lapses in memory wait
how old am i
i'm 25 wait am i 25 yeah i'm 25. so this
year i'm gonna be 26. a strong aversion
to anything new fangled hey hey hey hey
this is illegal we can't just be
watching me and drinking espresso plus
milk we have to be drinking
something else and oftentimes a decline
in some very basic motor functions
really
what do you see that spear do you see
that spirit i swear live games against
me jankos seemed to have been hit
particularly hard by that last one
especially when it came to playing
nidalee and that was a problem you see
when yankos and his teammates won msi in
2019 nidalee wasn't a very big part of
the meta but in 2020 and 2021 she became
one of the game's most important
junglers and serious pros had no choice
but to learn her or put their team at a
big disadvantage in draft now if you
don't know nidalee she's this fast power
farming skill shot centric champion
who's been around forever she comes with
loads of damage and poke and in the
right hands her spears can make a huge
difference on the rift but
in yankos's hands
that proved to be a different story
what how did that mean can just like try
to snowball right now
only i can throw a spear in between two
jungle monsters
[Laughter]
hi uncles today in school friend made
fun of me and told me that my mama is so
fat that even the uncle spirit can't
miss her like i'm not gonna hit a single
one if she has hands if she doesn't have
hands then maybe i will
oh that was kind of [__] move
soon enough yanko's infamous nidalee
whiffs became all anyone could talk
about and it produced some pretty
hilarious memes like you know that
there's a problem when mcdonald's
germany is calling you out on their
official twitter account
he's already dead now of course yankos
wouldn't be yankos if he simply accepted
defeat so instead he took motivation
from the mockery he was receiving and
put his nose to the grindstone to
spearhead his glorious comeback from
meme jail
my spirit just killed him i like that
me hitting a spear though is something
super unexpected and it wasn't just his
nidalee spears that saw a marked
improvement yankos was also using his
sage wisdom and experience in g2
transitioning from the hot-headed
superstar jungler into a stable veteran
presence who could lead his young
teammates by example this is gonna be
exciting it's gonna be gonna be loud so
we keep our comes clean and we play like
we play i guess game one could
definitely be the game where the biggest
dig wins okay so having the bigger dick
might be the advantage yeah okay
for sure
okay so fine yankos is still a hothead
but everything else i just said stands
he took all the criticism that had been
directed his way and not only used it as
motivation to silence his critics but to
drive his teammates on during the 2022
lec spring split playoffs the flame
trump is going down he'll escape still
has the flash that has the alt targets
he's still standing he's trying to get
the playset maybe he can get it off no
raspberry going to find one back not
always lost but jankos is here flag and
drag through everywhere razor wants to
be jankos has his number humanoid trying
to play towards the top side over here
comes jankos that's the stun caps
doesn't have any follow-up it might be
enough that's it that's the fourth stack
coming into the castle blows the but
wants a few more rampage fully stacked
it's going to be big damage he finally
manages to connect the stun jankos he's
still hungry
this play you can say jankos has washed
he's all his hands don't work anymore
but he's proving everyone wrong where
are the doubters at this is the point of
pressure fnatic eventually will have to
respond to 43.
is yanko's gonna go for the 50 50. he
has vision he has vision
going in
oh they want the 3-0 they can taste
victory in front of them fanatic now
they have to be scared but hit us like
that
broken maybe just to make it out black
it now in a killing three rounds or he's
in the midst of the entire team the gps
is big but it's not going to be big
enough upset lag down a massive ball but
it's all falling apart in the final
moments g2 tearing through fnatic this
was their last chance and they missed
it's a triple for jankos the follow-up
is there it is absolute dominance for g2
esports in the final fight 2-0 clean
control the final game oh
but the quadra for yankos yankos here
but really can you fight trimby locked
up yankers will take one man can he
queue
the pillar get back over here yankoff
brings melvan back and it'll be another
kill over to g2 caps on the chase with
the charm the fighting never ends trying
to defend they got a man advantage but
what can they do the shock boss goes
wide caps still advancing flash
challenge troopy takes it perfect play
by the support from
the death from below is enough
and the death of rogue is written in
stone
while the high of g2's spring season
victory might have been brought back to
earth by a semi-final smackdown against
t1 at msi yankos has proven himself to
be more than capable of navigating the
emotional roller coaster that is life as
a league pro and amazingly despite the
taxing ups and downs of the past few
years his competitive spirit remains
safely intact although that fact alone
hasn't stopped him from thinking about
what his next chapter might be but
honestly
playing competitive
it takes a tool on you
look at my hair
is one of the things that
really got hit hard when i became a pro
player
and you have no free time and you have
no life
and i cannot
i i just don't see myself being a pro
gamer when i have a child and a wife the
future is clearly on yanko's mind and it
shows in the amount of time he's begun
investing into building a loyal twitch
following now when his fans aren't
watching him compete in the lec they're
turning up by the thousands to see what
other nonsense he's getting up to
oh my god it's awkward actually
[Laughter]
that's so awkward like holy [__] that's
so good i need water in my pocket
they want to kill me
they wanted to kill me okay it's just a
zombie guys it's just a zombie like how
can a grown adult be a scared of a
zombie it's just a game
oh my god my life at the end of the day
like all pros yankos recognizes that an
esports career comes with an expiry date
fans may think they know when that is
but ultimately it's the players who know
when they've got nothing left in the
tank and right now that's clearly not
the case for jankos sure he might not be
the bravest man out there when it comes
to dealing with the digital undead but
yankos has proven that he definitely
isn't afraid to confront serious
real-life challenges head-on need to
find a way to bond with new teammates
easy eyes because fans wanted it that
was the worst zoo ever
yeah yeah i know yeah i can yell but not
the shoe i know that's true don't say it
like you but i cannot say it this is yes
yeah yeah
let's go boys yes can't land a spear to
save your life get better yeah i think
that's that's actually okay right that's
fine i get i got a scene shop
old age getting you down homie you're
26. i suppose i'm like a big brother
team right and i do tend to have strong
opinions about in-game and also outside
of the game behavior so i think that
they just treat me as
their older brother but it could be a
grandpa as well i suppose so in short
where there is a will there is always a
way no matter what anyone thinks and
yankos is the perfect example of using
haters and naysayers to fuel your
progress both as a player and as a
person good vision nidalee lover high
kill participation aggressive jungler
nothing negative about me in italy there
you go
there you go
he's such a funny guy man i'm so glad we
did not beat on him he's such he's so
funny
his laugh is like
i really like him he's a jokes guy i
would love to do
um
oh it would be so funny especially
because he's a jungler too right he's
both really good at the game or like
really cracked but also just like
a funny guy just a really funny guy